on va bien chaque fois qu une propriété
mise en vente les acheteurs se
bousculent les offres d'achat multiples
sont devenus monnaie courante
des fois il peut avoir eu 50 visites
dizaines d'acheteurs potentiels qui sont
intéressés à l'acheter puis la basse et
jean alost ont tous une offre puis le
secret une surenchère un bel inventaire
une augmentation de la demande de
propriété c'est la recette parfaite pour
une augmentation des prix dans le grand
montréal le prix médian d'une maison à
deux étages a bondi de 22% en un an pour
atteindre plus de 680 mille dollars
la hausse est de 20 % pour les maisons
de plain pied à 420 milles dollars et de
15% pour les copropriétés à près de 400
mille dollars
il ya des gens qui souvent se retrouver
bientôt peut-être qu'ils se retrouvent
présentement hors du marché à cause de
l'augmentation drastique des prix le cpo
produire les aider dans certains titres
de propriété on parle de plus de 100000
dollars d'augmentation le serein sur un
an
donc c'est sûr c'est très inquiétant
selon québec solidaire il faut apaiser
le marché immobilier enlevant la
confidentialité des offres d'achat donc
les acheteurs mais ne dépose pas des
autres les achats à la veille
il le dépose des offres d'achat tout en
connaissant les autres qui sont sur la
table mais selon dominic st pierre c'est
une solution qui pourrait avoir un effet
boomerang
le fait que les gens soient au courant
des offres concurrentielles ça
favoriserait encore plus de surenchère
les gens probablement et tous cas encore
plus en compétition avec l'autre toutes
mesures artificielles voix calme il joue
un peu mais éventuellement le marché
immobilier c'est l'offre et la demande
est présentement il ya plus de demande
que d'offre
et ça va fort le régler en construisant
plus de propriétés plus accessible à un
plus grand nombre de personnes ces clans
qui manque d'une famille à la cause de
la mort hier ni en manque à ce seul
produit qui recherchait en ce moment ce
serait de convaincre côté des promoteurs
d'en construire plus parce que puisqu'il
se bâtissent et de la copropriété en ce
moment alors parce que c'est plus
rentable pour les promoteurs mais les
municipalités pourraient être favorisées
plus de constructions de maisons de
ville ou de la propriété familiale
le problème est complexe les pistes de
solutions sont nombreuses
reste à voir si québec voudra s'en mêler
ici olivier bachand réseau canada
montréal